[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in zach jackson who covers
the browns and the nfl for the athletic
why make this decision now zach why is
baker not playing next week why did he
play last week
well the simple answer is the browns are
eliminated and by the time they were
officially eliminated dan he had already
put in the week of preparation but you
know what's most notable from that
conversation is he said i'm going to
talk to my agents i'm going to talk to
my family before we officially decide he
did not say i'm going to talk to the
coach not going to talk to the browns so
it feels like it's brown's dysfunction
season again there's an incredible level
of disappointment
and the offense just bottomed out over
the uh you know last couple months of
the season so
no doubt baker was hurt but
he just did not play well and it felt
like the disconnect was always there
really going back to october
and so what's next you know none of us
know but you know from someone who
covers the browns it feels like baker's
gonna go on ir and that's the last time
we're gonna hear from him for a long
long time i mentioned this a couple
times during the show and i apologize to
my audience for repeating myself but
i'll say it to you when you play through
pain and you're successful
we write stories about you they make
movies about that
he played through pain and didn't play
well
were the browns better served with him
in there playing hurt or would they have
been better served with case keenum you
know there were times going back to the
middle part of the season where i wrote
there's no way that they're playing the
best quarterback like he's in such pain
and he's playing so poorly that he's not
giving them the best chance so we come
to december they have their bye week the
gm andrew barry goes on the record and
says baker is healthy enough to win and
we expect him to play his best over the
last five weeks that did not happen so
now you add the contract situation the
guarantee for next year it really just
like i said bottoming out four
interceptions on christmas day nine
sacks the other night he he says the
protection scheme you know gave him no
chance
um we don't know where this is going to
go but it's it's clearly you know no joy
around the team and a big question on
his future because i don't think the
browns can win with baker mayfield and
the browns have to decide is there a
better option and there might not be and
what do you do you know how much do you
weigh the injury in deciding can you
bring him back next year to a roster
that's really good and the defense was
lights out over the past five or six
games explain his contract if you can
so they picked up the fifth year option
on his rookie deal uh last may and when
they did that that was a no-brainer so
he's guaranteed to make 19 million
dollars next year that that money's
guaranteed if they were to trade him it
would be no dead money but i think they
want to move on dan i just don't know
what a better option would be
free agency doesn't you know provide a
great one if you wanted to say go the
mariota or mitch trubisky route could
baker coexist with those guys and then
realistically could you go make a trade
for russell wilson for deshaun watson
for derek carr you know no one knows
right now and if those guys do get
traded the browns certainly aren't going
to be the only suitor
i like what the browns have i mean they
have the nucleus here to be a great team
and a lot of people had high
expectations for this team and it's not
just on baker i don't know if you got to
see the manning cast zach but the
mannings in real time
were really calling out kevin stefanski
and baker mayfield with what
what's the game plan here the formation
here you got a guy with a banged up
shoulder tj watt is running wild here um
they were
they were pretty critical of the browns
uh
is stefanski facing this criticism
locally
yeah he is um that's not the only game
that we set in the press box or set
where we sat and said said the same
thing right i mean they haven't had the
full complement of running backs when
they've had chubb and hunt together
they've averaged 28 points a game um
otherwise they've struggled to get over
14 so but yeah were they two pass happy
yes is this all on baker no but there
were a lot of times he either didn't see
or couldn't see guys there's a lot of
times he missed guys and then you go
back at the end of the game and you do
say why in this situation is he throwing
34 times 36 times so you go back to the
bigger question why is he even out there
if he's in this much pain and this is
his performance because it wasn't once
it wasn't twice it was multiple times
where he played some of the worst games
an nfl quarterback could play and i'm
thinking about this if aaron rodgers is
going to be in the market they're going
to want to trade him to an afc team not
an nfc team so denver and cleveland
could compete for him
desean watson who knows what's going to
happen there i don't know if it matters
where he goes just that he finally goes
i don't know if you look at the draft
um
if you could if you could have a gap
year year um
i don't know there it just feels like
there's uncertainty there with baker
mayfield
and and it feels like he's calling a lot
more shots than he should be calling
given his position is that a fair
assessment uh i think he's trying to
call those i think we don't know who's
really calling them right these guys
have been there for two years we had the
pandemic the first year was kumbaya
everything was great it was the best
season this franchise has had in 20
years and this year it bottomed out and
so to the fan base to ownership this is
the second time in three years that
baker's played poorly and the
expectations have not been met i agree
the roster's good expectations should be
high so what happens is i think they
pursue a trade but you know if you can't
get one of those top guys that you
mentioned then you probably can't do you
really want to go to matt ryan road kirk
cousins you know i'd be all for derek
carr if you can do it i don't know that
you can do it he's under contract for
one more year the raiders will have to
decide when they get their new bosses so
the draft doesn't look great you know
maybe the browns will be picking 10th or
11th and they'll consider that
but i think dan i think the team wants
to move on i just don't know what those
options will be as they present
themselves four weeks and even you know
all the way through four or six months
from now and you got the rise of joe
burrow and the cincinnati bengals like
you know ohio being from ohio
i know how this works you know the
buckeyes got a great quarterback the
bengals got a great quarterback brown's
not so much
yeah and it's like a year from now if
bryce young cj stroud who you just
mentioned like the browns aren't going
to be in position to be ticking picking
my top five quarterback right so
they're re they're built to win now and
that's the urgency i do think like i
said that i do think they will go after
a quarterback but i can't say with any
level of certainty and i don't think
they can either right now you know can
you really trade for an a-plus
quarterback or even a b-plus quarterback
um you know and go forward thinking you
can win the super bowl next year
uh now that odell beckham is gone and
producing for the rams was how much of a
problem
was odell beckham to this team yeah that
was a big part of the season i mean
baker's made vague mentions to internal
strife and and we're left to assume um
that a lot of it was then because he's
just never answered it but you know i
just think there was frustration as to
fancy mentioned this of the results um
of the injury but just time and time
again they needed to make simple passes
and they couldn't do it and they threw
too much right and and so
to to sit and watch at home sunday know
that your playoff chances are dead and
then go get them sacked nine times on
monday it's
it's it was the most disappointing end
and now we lead to a period of complete
uncertainty the ideal situation dan was
baker plays well he earns the contract
the browns go forward they finally have
their guy this is the exact opposite of
that would you rather cover a boring
good team
or a very interesting average or bad
team
uh i'm here for the interesting there's
no doubt no it was great last year when
the browns won and they finally broke
all these streaks that dated back to
2002 and even back some to the 90s but
they're not dull and we'll see um you
know quarterback searches are good for
business
zach great appearance thank you we
appreciate your time and uh good luck
with the athletic all right thank you
that's zach jackson he covers the browns
nfl writer for the athletic